this is french guiana the northeast
coast of South America I'm here for one
of the most difficult fixes humankind is
ever really attempt starts here the
equatorial rainforest and then orbiting
the earth above us in space
there's only a handful of places on the
planet that can pull off a job like this
strap yourself in for this one and this
is definitely out of this world but it's
fixed we're going satellite launching
very few people can access to a fix like
this it's like driving a semi truck into
a takeout window yeah your fries with
that rocket okay okay and just to be
sure everything I'm looking at right
there is solid gold right so let's go
yes that's why you cannot approach
riding along on patrol with the French
Foreign Legion you can see they take
security very seriously
24 hours a day it's their job to be
ready for anything
I'd like to give all of that training
I'd like to check that out oh you're
welcome
what
ha
the name is matt l feel you can do
welcome to engine there's no prize here
no no it's not you they don't want the
price tag because if you have to ask you
can't afford it no snow struck dude is
the chemical proof waterproof meet our
zippers going up out of my head if I set
back to launch by one week if it was me
yeah I will be payable okay okay you'd
be fired and I would be very unpopular
yeah I see I think so
we have got a huge movement out of it
this is a really really tricky
it's hard to believe that all hard work
everybody's but that's all coming down
to this 10 seconds seven seas that's in
five seconds their homes pulled away
and she'd started that's it the Vulcan
rocket started up that'll burn for just
a 50 seconds it's good they're nodding
the Boosters there it is
as life tough